aiuto scappiamo scappiamo tutto No aiuto
ho sbagliato Aiuto aiuto questa testa di
pagliaccio gigante qua fa paura che è
brutto Sì il pagliaccio terrificante
oggi nuovissimo Escape Room dovremmo
scappare da questa persona giocava
adesso è il pagliaccio terrificante in
tempo per carnevale quasi Comunque è
bruttissimo E noi siamo laggiù nella
prigione vedete
Ciao ciao Dobbiamo riuscire a scappare
da questa prigione vedrete solo qua sono
qua aiuto Fatemi scappare dappertutto
cosa ho sbagliato sono talmente
spaventato che sto andando a quattro
zampe è vero che stai gattonando tu la
dietro Boh vabbè come sempre lasciate un
mi piace Mettetevi comodi prendete i
Popcorn e iniziamo questo nuovo
avventura assieme È vero Eccoci qua
nella prigione Ok Che cosa dobbiamo fare
Ehi c'è il Mercoledì Addams guarda cioè
ho fatto cadere
ti arrabbierà molto ha detto Allora
saliamo qui Ah ecco perché bisogna
mettersi in piedi tipo
e il pagliaccio e là dentro non capisco
come si deve fare per mettersi in piedi
eh Ma come fai tu a metterti a quattro
zampe
non riesco più a mettermi i piedi però è
pazienza tu rimarrai così per tutte le
Skype eh eh come faccio
Ciao ciao Vitale
io salgo qua su io scappo ciao
Non ho capito il mio outfit di oggi Oggi
sono messo unicorno e poi in mezzo
Sailor Moon con il vestito rosa al
fiocchetto Ciao ciao Vitale io me ne
vado andrò avanti io lo vedo che ti stai
alzando e ti stai abbassando ma
veramente sì ora sei in piedi ma io sono
comunque
Ehi ma io ti vedo in piedi ma non
capisco perché
l'Italia vede tutto dal basso
Ok Vitale ha dovuto rinascere perché
altrimenti avrebbe bloccato
allora A proposito di carnevale così che
cosa vi travestirete questo carnevale Io
adoro carnevale è una delle mie feste
preferite dopo Halloween perché
Halloween sapete ovviamente le cose
paurose Ma ti sei seduto nell'acqua ti
stavo ascoltando
[Applauso]
Ma poi Come si fa questa poltroncina in
un'escape Room Power pagliaccio cattivo
carnevale aiuto Guarda che questa testa
di pagliaccio gigante qua fa paura
paglia che brutto Oh mamma è bruttissima
ho una sfida per te Vediamo chi riesce
ad avvicinarsi di più al pagliaccio
senza morire
però non mi fa niente non mi fa niente
fa niente
Ciao ciao
che è successo Ho scoperto un passaggio
segreto
Cioè praticamente sono saltata qua qua
c'è il pagliaccio Ah ah ah
Non era un passaggio segreto era una
trappola Ah Se ci vedete così strani
Cioè che io sono nella luce più Angelica
semplicemente perché oggi è una giornata
passata c'è una nuvola su Vitale come la
nuvola di Fantozzi Questo era l'effetto
fulmini Oh aspetta un momento mi ha
fatto ricominciare ah ah Pensavo fosse
ricominciato da capo Però
in realtà Eccovi Ciao Ok Allora dobbiamo
ah ah Aspetta dobbiamo saltare qua non
andare dal pagliaccio è una trappola Ah
ma perché non hai aspettato te Ah ma io
vedo che stai saltando sull'aria Che
bello Sono viva Com'è possibile che solo
lui la stessa saltando nell'aria è tutto
grazie a questa luce Angelica di oggi
si nasconde dietro dietro il divano Ma
che dici Non c'è niente qua guarda Ah
che voto via via via eh È scomparso ciao
ciao ciao ciao ciao ciao
il tempo è super strano in questi giorni
anche al Sud purtroppo è arrivato
l'inverno cioè freddissimo fateci sapere
da voi Che tempo fa se c'è freddo se c'è
la neve ok Abbiamo sistemato la luce
Angelica ora sono mi vedete un po'
meglio ah ah trova le chiavi Apri la
porta benissimo
Sto provando a correre ma è incastrato
non si riesce perché apre la bocca così
perché ci vuole mangiare
un panino gigante No no manco per niente
No guarda cosa Ah questa è la stessa
chiave che hai trovato No io ho trovato
un'altra chiave perché ho tre chiavi
adesso
qua prendo una chiave posso prendere
500.000 km
credo che ce ne servirà solo una a meno
che non possiamo tirarlo in casa ho
sbagliato Beccati questo Ho aperto la
porta Ops non dovevo avvicinarmi troppo
dall'occhietto d'oro Oh mamma mia anche
tolto la chiave
e poi c'è una chiave anche sopra Sì va
bene una qualsiasi credo eh perché mi
hanno messo così tante pensavo che non
avremmo trovato quell'altra Dai vieni
il pavimento è lavabile ma non sono il
pavimento anche tu mi stavo sfracellando
C'è mancato poco
affettati dal laser ci siamo cascati
tutti e due Ok cerchiamo di andare piano
non possiamo attraversare quella cosa
fantastica
Ma perché mi sono partite i capelli Ti
puoi abbassare e andare di là però io
non lo so sono andato Da quest'altra
parte
il pagliaccio Guarda sono una trappola
quella e poi se guardiamo là ci sono
delle fiamme quindi può essere che sia
una trappola però noi siamo coraggiosi
vero e quindi proveremo a passare qui
stasera devi prepararci c'è pure scritto
bravi
Sì ma non funziona Oh
E allora prendi quello Brava Ah ecco
non ci credo
Ehi tu dove sei e sono qui su
quest'altra parte
Ah ah ah hai vinto veramente fa stare
qua il pagliaccio Era solo per cercare
di spaventarsi e non farti passare qua
qua preferisco comunque andare da quella
parte perché perché
va bene No per questa volta andiamo di
qua ok Dove sei agitando le fiabe
attento è un po' difficile questa parte
dell'escape Room Dov'è Vitale Ah eccolo
là sopra Oh no ma qua bisogna stare
super attenti andare piano piano piano
ci sono le fiamme Come hai fatto ad
attraversare queste fiamme Beh non so
come ma le fiamme non ti fanno niente
su queste palline rosse dai Qua possiamo
rotolare rotolare giù per la collina
proviamo a rotolare giù Anzi facciamo
una gara ora che arrivi qua vediamo
rotoliamo assieme giù per l'acqua
non è giusto Ok Wow Wow
ci vuole proprio una bella nuotata
adesso che c'è un freddo ma poi assurdo
nell'acqua non va bene prendi la scossa
Eh beh Quelli sono dei laser speciali
tipo Minecraft questo questo pavimento
il pavimento in Minecraft invece che
lava
Oh sono in vantaggio sono riuscito a non
sfracellarmi Ciao sono arrivato
veloce ho sbagliato ci sono tutti i
pagliacci là sotto li avete visti
flagellato Ehi Aspetta ma di nuovo da
capo da dove mi ha fatto ricominciare da
qua dai è andata più avanti
per questo gioco È buggato Forse non
l'avevi salvato sì che è salvato È solo
che sinceramente non c'era il punto per
salvare Sì sì certo no aspetta perché
siamo morta Non ho fatto niente di
strano Sì ma quanti spingi ci sono in
queste Escape Room Allora noi siamo allo
stage 13 e quello più avanti di tutti è
il 18 quindi forse ne mancano ancora
cinque Forse sei sette devo Sbrigati a
prendere il badge nuotiamo qua
e devo anche prendere un po' d'aria
altrimenti
mi fa salvare perché
[Musica]
c'era scritto Check Point e quindi
perché mi ha fatto ricominciare da là
vediamo ora da dove mi farà ricominciare
perché sono così schiappa oggi non lo so
OK riproviamo Da questo lato forse
saremo più fortunati qua via
[Musica]
aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta che
brutto Ok vai
però puoi saltare un pochettino più in
alto Cioè nel senso perché sempre qua
come una pera Vai a saltare
Ok adesso co co co co co co co co le
ginocchia Allora vai ok puoi andare Vai
vai rincorsa Ok brava Ancora un altro lo
puoi fare bravo
e quindi questa è la zipline Ah sei
salito ancora Oh
Aiuto c'è un pagliaccio era così veloce
aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto Ok Questa
volta ce l'ho fatta saltiamo qui su
questi posti
è arrivato Vitale dove sei avanti Ciao
Non mi sia che hai preso peggio No
ancora no salta e prendi il vento c'è
scritto qua il vento sto prendendo il
vento come fai a prendere quello sul
vento
Allora ecco perché qui
No che figata Non ci credo questo
sarebbe la super velocità non lo so come
ho fatto però prova a saltare sempre
vedi che riuscirai a passare saltiamo
continua Continua
dai andiamo avanti Oh Qui bisogna stare
sopra attenti perché qua basta un minimo
movimento sbagliato e cadiamo nella Lava
e poi e siamo super in alto anche Quindi
piano piano
allontanati Non ti azzardare sono io
davanti Tanto ora ti supera lo stesso
piano piano piano piano piano piano
piano piano
piano
pazzesca
Dai sbrigati sei troppo lento Guarda
sono ancora qui e ora di Slime
devi premere un pulsante per togliere le
grate Ah bene Qua c'è uno Slime Ehi
perché sono morta niente Ah eccoti
Quante volte mi sono sfracellato questo
curriculum non ho fatto niente Non so
cosa bisogna fare qua sicuramente non
bisogna calpestare queste cose devi aver
capito non bisogna toccare il muro hai
capito Ok ho capito
Non toccare il muro però eh
Ci sono le bolle qui tipo
cos'è non lo stesso provando a prendere
questo regalo Allora io è uscito una
maschera bruttissima che dice donatore
di badge porte 2 perché sono morta
pure io sono morto
però posso volare in alto in alto in
alto Guarda guarda normale Fatemi
correre normale non voglio essere il
pagliaccio voglio essere riso pronto Non
l'avevo visto abbiamo vinto ma ci ha
trasformato i pagliacci Ma come volevo
dire questo Ho vinto vi ho trasformati
Beh vediamo se posso tormentare Vitale
adesso dove sei Esatto
Non si capisce qui che cosa c'è
giochiamo ricomincia a giocare
Slime Zombie il gioco
copriamolo assieme
barriera protettiva e cioè adesso arriva
anche i luoghi
bisogna colpire Guarda Oh tipo un'arma
qua posso chiamare lo zoom fico
sopra questo ponte sopra il ponte qua
dove sono io guarda l'ho trovata però
bisogna trovare anche i guardiani Allora
credo che spunterà fuori fra poco
vediamo Forse da sopra Riusciamo a
vederlo bene
Esci fuori è tutto un po' Strano questo
gioco un po' buggato come tutti i giochi
di girarlo praticamente Chi è che mi sta
Come vi siete permessi sono eliminarmi
dovevo provare Vergognati colpire tutti
Non sono akiwaki paracadute c'è un
paracadute
quel paracadute poi Ehi Aspetta forse
devo colpire questo balzo Bonzo Come si
chiamava Bonzo il coniglietto di
Chi è che sta sparando si sta sparando
così
questo non
scomparendo dei punti finchè non compare
anche i luoghi sparerò questi Bonzo Ehi
tu Non avvicinarti troppo Vai via invece
un albero al contrario
[Musica]
del pagliaccio Come sempre voi lasciate
un mi piace e ora qua vi lasciamo
quattro caselline su pubblicare per
vedere i nostri altri video cliccate su
quello che preferite Buona visione Ciao